as promised my compadre from the NFL
Network NFL Media Group and we survived
eight and a half hours of pregame show
together yesterday and it is a Super
Bowl edition of Monday's with mu cheer
on the Rich Eisen show how you doing
Steve Mariucci I'm doing good rich I'm
at the airport right now getting outta
Dodge yep and I see a lot of sad
Patriots hands and I see a lot of crazy
Eagle you had to get out of here oh boy
well I'm wondering which call do you
think was more you know I guess I don't
want to have more stake to it but there
were two fourth down calls by Doug
Peterson yesterday that without either
one of them I think the Patriots are the
ones who are happy in that Airport today
that fourth down call instead of kicking
a field goal in the first half that
wound up with Nick Foles grabbing a
touchdown and then obviously going for
it on the minus side of the field in the
fourth quarter on fourth down which one
do you think was more stones mooch well
you know first of all rich Doug Peterson
and the Eagles converted 17 fourth downs
this year 17 out of 28 I guess which is
the most in the league and so he's a
he's a little bit of a risk-taker and
it's been good to him and the other
thing is he you know he went for a lot
of two-point conversions and you saw
that early in the game too and so he was
pulling out all the stops from the
get-go but the one to Nick Foles for a
touchdown which kind of coincidentally
came after Tom Brady's incomplete pass
to him evidently that was a call that
Nick that play Nick Foles ran that in
high school okay so they they went way
back they went back to Nick Foles
offense when he's with Chip Kelly they
went back to his high school they did
some fun things that a Nick Foles felt
good about and they've been practicing
it for a few weeks and it called it at
the right time is wide open great
perfect execution but that didn't
surprise me as much as the fourth down
call that you
virtue in their own territory pick more
than one and then of course they
converted it to get the tight end for a
first down
that one was a gutsy call I'm not sure
I'm not sure I'd have done that one but
it's your work form well I mean I guess
he figured that those are the sorts of
moments you need to me it reminded me
it's up there with Sean Payton going on
aside to kick off the second half right
because the Saints you know received the
opening kickoff and then they did the
onside kick on the second half and God
it made it they so they had an opening
possession in both halves that's how you
beat a Peyton Manning so I guess you
figure you gotta take some chances right
now once in a while here you know it's
been forever since you've been here you
might as well just let her rip yeah
because to me he felt that he needed to
somehow someway steal a possession or
continue obviously his own possession
and then when urge scored
I thought they left way too much time on
the clock for Tom Brady that was my
first thought
like why are all the Eagles fans
celebrating take you believe those two
when there's two in change to go to two
and change right and and of course the
sack strip fumble and Derek Barnett
recovery it was like okay if your
defense is ever going to make a stop in
this game I'm talking Patriots defense
this is it because you can keep this to
a one-possession game they had good use
of their time outs they took the time
out with 203 then they had the
two-minute warning stop the clock and it
was in that defense of the Patriots
really you know stiffened and forced the
field goal and kept it a one possession
game for Tom Brady and all five of his
Super Bowls that he's won he it required
a game-winning drive so it's like here
we go again you left too much time twice
for Tom Brady but then Brandon Graham
made the defensive play of the night
pretty much the only pressure that I
think either quarterback felt for for
much of the night and and that really
changed the fortunes and even with all
that is
that the the Patriots had one last throw
to the end zone to win it Steve Mariucci
joining me here is he's flying out of
town here on the Rich Eisen show from
the Superbowl city of Minneapolis yeah
where's Brandon Graham from that's right
well look don't think I didn't notice
that Brady bringing try to move the ball
in he was tucking it away just as a
Michigan man rolled with what Michigan
on Michigan crying with Woodson that's
right this one was Brandon Graham and
falls Falls would spend a cup of coffee
in East Lansing as we all know before in
his in his journey I mean what in the
world do you think is going through Nick
Foles his brain this morning Steve you
know he's such a squared-away kid you
saw his daughter on the stage and he saw
he doesn't get to up or to down he takes
it all he stride he sees the class act
and he fits in over there it's gonna be
a you know what'll be the offseason
discussion what do you do with Nick
Foles if you're Holly Roseman but rich I
I would think he's just very grateful
that he had this opportunity and
delivered for his teammates but I but I
also do think they're gonna have to make
business decisions with him is awesome
is that city is fired up about Nick
Foles they are loyal to Carson Wentz you
know that there's no controversy over
there and I think they're going to keep
him on the roster as a backup next year
at 4 million dollars and then CL Carson
Wentz leg holds up they can kind of play
them through this season and then before
the draft over the trade deadline I mean
then they can decide if they're going to
trade Nick Foles but I certainly
wouldn't do it now because you don't
know if you're going to get Carson Wentz
healthy in the first game or not so I'd
go with that pitching staff again for
the opening of the season and decide
next year so what about Malcolm Butler
Steve I mean it's really odd that
somebody who plays 98 percent of the
defensive snaps all year long as Matt
Patricia said after the game that they
that the packages or the rotation just
didn't call for him to be out there and
Belichick saying it wasn't something
disciplinary that
him off the field what in the world do
you think happened with him well I don't
know what happened what I was thinking
it was disciplinary though that's what I
was thinking I mean for crying out loud
he won the Super Bowl for him couple
years ago when he intercepted Russell
Wilson's pass so you think he might be
one of the guys that could help him win
and then and then when they're doing
Nick Foles throw the ball around like
crazy you go Hawaii I wonder if I don't
play Malcom Butler explain its best in
special teams but I don't know what
happened or about the scheme about any
discipline but it's it's strange that
one of their very good football players
was not on the field helping him out
because Nick Foles lost for 380 yards
and they can't stop them so they're not
gonna they're not going to give you any
answers I you know how that works but
it's a good kid I think he's going to be
a free agent too he said he played his
last game he said that they gave up on
him that's what he said that the team
gave up on him I mean that is just that
is truly one of the more bizarre aspects
of last night I don't think we'll ever
know because unless he leaves and tells
the story but I I don't think we're
gonna hear it from the Pats why he
didn't play but it's just one of those
other storylines in kind of earnest look
to be a factor in this game all right
before I let you go on your flight there
Steve I mean what sort of coaching job
do you think Doug Peterson did I'd love
to give you the floor here I mean the
guy loses his he loses his left tackle
he loses his starting quarterback we
could go on and on yeah I think I'm
really proud of them and you know I
watched him grow up in this league from
a young backup quarterback never really
got much chance to play but he was a
student of the game always was a student
of the game
and he had a study like crazy because he
never got a lot of reps so he certainly
has done well for himself and and he
relates well with the players having
dinner I could think about this you have
a backup quarterback in Doug Peterson
that was his role in the NFL as a player
offensive coordinator Frank Wright he's
a backup quarterback had some great
comeback wins and all that
me and they win a Super Bowl with a
backup quarterback in Nick Foles and
it's kind of like you know the guys that
weren't the superstar the five star
athletes or the Pro Bowlers coming to
coming to roost and all of all of these
guys are having great success together
and you know what the Eagles are you
know with all those injuries you know
Jason Peters at left tackle and and in
all of these guys are comebacks rolls
next year you know with two good
quarterbacks you know there he quit
pretty well to try to stay on top and be
the favorite it's going to be fun to
watch but I'm so proud of Doug Peterson
for what he represents he's a great man
and a great coach yeah that clique that
kid Clemente Kurt Warner's x-factor he
was constant in the Super Bowl where
some kid becomes kids hits the stage and
is you know and and and just has the
huge spotlight cast on them and then who
knows moving forward they got a giant in
the middle of the season I mean it all
clicked for them and I'll be honest
Harvey that's such a good job in
LeGarrette Blount they added to that
team and all the points they scored in
the playoffs or newbies all new guys
that date that Holly Roseman either
traded for drafted brand new guys that
contributed like crazy and they all be
back next year hmm
unbelievable all right mooch great
season great times I'll see you soon at
the combine yeah before I got you golden
I guess with which which kid are you
looking forward most to seen at the
combine get yanma getting on that grease
board and doing doing the interviews for
NFL Network I can't wait to see these
quarterbacks because there's gonna it's
a really good class there's probably
going to be four guys drafted in the
first round in terms of quarterbacks and
Baker Mayfield Josh Allen and the two la
kids would Rosen and Arnold and so and
it's not just about them it's just it's
I just love watching this new talent
come into our league you know about 300
kids from this year's class will be
playing in our league next year and so
I'd like to see what they look like in
their underwear weighing in over there
in his measured up let's go I can't wait
just two weeks away all right
which say flight thanks again for
calling it as much you did this year you
got it
Steve Mariucci calling in from the
Minneapolis Airport where we're headed
after this day is over here the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience